[Music]
the design of this bottle started in
Terre Haute Indiana in 1915 at the time
coca-cola was being sold at soda
fountains or in a glass bottle called
the ketchup but this simple straight
sided bottle was easy to copy and
imitations were flooding the market the
solution a national contest for a new
bottle that we make coca-cola stand out
even if the bottle were broken or you
touched it in the dark the roof glass
company got to work on their competition
entry looking up the word Coca in the
encyclopedia and coming across an
illustration for a cocoa pod the curvy
Ridge shape appealed to the team who
used it as the basis for their winning
design the first bottles hit the shelves
just a year later with the added touch
of the glass being colored with German
green later changed to Georgia green in
honor of the coca-cola company's own the
state sleek and iconic this is the
design that seblak uses curves become
the trademark of the most popular drink
in the world
[Music]
you